what up guys and welcome back to episode
two of the great area with myself sarah
and just pearly things
right this is the show
called the gray area because
we like to delve into the areas of
society that make people a little bit
uncomfortable maybe a little bit gray
right but you know we want to hear your
views and we want to hear the views of
the people on the panel so um like pearl
always says if you have watched two or
more
videos on this channel and you have not
subscribed and we got beat tell them
okay we have beef
so do that right now uh so before we get
started people don't say anything
okay guys do not forget to like this
video on your way in it is really
important to the algorithm that you like
the video on top of that all super chats
will be read also i have put just in
charge of our behind the scenes um for
memberships so if you want to see some
exclusive behind-the-scenes content sign
up for our membership so
let's get started yeah all right um
we're gonna go around each one of you as
you as you guys know or you guys know
today's topic is interracial
relationships okay so we're gonna go
around and just say your name uh your
age and your relationship status will go
left
cool my name is malik
i've been dating for a year now
with my girlfriend for a year and i'm
24.
hi my name is morella i've been single
for a while now and i am 31.
hi my name is elia i'm 24 and i'm in a
relationship
my name's called chloe carter i'm 23 and
i am in a relationship
hi my name is daley i'm 26 and i'm in a
relationship
nice all right people in relationships
people not all right so let's get
started let's just ask the question is
anyone here in an interracial
relationship yeah i'm there
why
what do you mean why why
why am i an integration yeah why why not
something else is it does it matter does
it not matter um
it depends because i've actually thought
about this i've read the book um black
economics by jawanza kufufu
and he talks about the reason why the
black community is disintegrated is
because
or so economically one of the reasons
why we're at the bottom of the barrel um
in pretty much every country including
even in africa
is that we
interracially day outside so when you
look at other communities if you look at
the indian community such as the
gujarati community they date within they
don't
it's not predicated on anything else in
terms of they don't talk about it they
just do
and the the idea about that is
collectively they they collectively the
identity stays as one when you have kids
and they're interracial kids they're
grown up in fragmented communities that
aren't necessarily theirs because you
can't leverage of both and that's me
coming from i'm mixed race myself you
end up being in between a rock and a
hard place between the two so to put
into live examples when you look at say
good rarities wherever they go they're
always top of the economic food chain
when you look at 74 of indians within
the uk own the houses while africans is
20 and caribbean's is 40.
not drawing any causal link but when you
look at it um
black the black community interracially
dates more than any other community out
there but then it comes down to what is
the most important thing to you
so
to give another example martin luther
king
he is the most important thing to him
was the fervent of the black people so
as a
as a byproduct of that he died broke and
so did malcolm x
see be the the betterment of my people
is something that i put above a lot of
things but i don't put that over my self
gratitude and love and even when i look
at say my financial views that's why
i've become more conservative as i've
grown older because i want to elevate my
people but not the detriment of myself
and when you look at say i've gone on a
tangent but look at like tour reviews
it's about
what matters for you and part of that is
capitalism the same way when i put love
i put that over
other people because the reality is do
these man give the same [ __ ] about me
i'm most loyal to myself than i am to
anyone else so i have a question go
ahead what percent of um black people do
you think they interracially
um i don't know the uh but one thing i
do know in the uk it's more than every
any other race combined well i can't
tell i can't tell you a flatland so i
was just curious because when you were
talking you said it was more yeah but
it's it's still 85
in the uk i i don't let me see i don't
think that's this way this might be the
u.s yeah this is definitely not the uk
i'll tell you that okay yeah okay i can
check i can you know check check to let
me know
do you know i don't believe you'll ever
get an accurate number on that because a
lot of people aren't willing to come
forward on their interracial
relationships or be honest about them at
all so
yeah that's interesting you you sounded
you when daley was talking you were like
you sound like you had something to say
yeah no i'm surprised i'm surprised
because to read black economics and then
be with a
date outside the race is a very strange
thing to actually be able to take from
something from it and then no but that's
still i don't know
i never said that's what i took from the
book i'm saying that this is what the
book that talks about but i've even said
and i explained i put my love and i put
my self-actualization yeah over the
black struggle so isn't it i'm loyal to
myself before i'm loyal to my people i'm
so loyal to my people too but all
because
i day outside my race i could do more
for my race than someone that dates with
inside their race because there's a bag
of black black conservatives who they'll
date within their race but in terms of
supporting the welfare state they'll
dodge tax and won't give a [ __ ] about
philanthropy so where are you going with
it oh because does that automatically
qualify you
is this like for example following a
religion because you follow religion
does that automatically qualify you as a
good person or because you follow
religion no and there's people who are
unholy doing good acts all the time no
you're you're missing me slightly yeah
so go ahead you
you know wherever they go
then number one at least within
minorities you know and actually a lot
of them own their homes all that kind of
stuff yeah to then go from that
knowing that you know it doesn't it's
not really about themselves it's about
their people
it's it's an unspoken thing
um to then speak on the fact that the
your reason is you
no i didn't say my reasoning i said i
thought i thought i thought about that
and i've it then explained that i put
myself over that reason so that is my
reasoning i put myself over that
that's interesting anyone else in the
interracial relationship
been there done that
got the
t-shirt anymore
you say no anymore why not anymore
i don't know i just
i think because
because of how i've grown up
like when i grew up i grew up in like a
predominantly white area and it was kind
of like all i knew until i moved to
london and i got to know like more black
people and then started dating more
black people but i never dated a lot of
the black let's say for example the
black people that went to my school were
always a bit like um
not like bit like bullyish to me so i
kind of just tended to hang around with
white people a bit more because i got
labeled as a coconut from like a really
young age so i there was a lot of
self-hatred there when i was young
because of like treatment that i had
from other like black folk which
i took to heart which i shouldn't have
and that in turn led to me kind of
wanting to stay away from dating black
guys so i i did date um like white guys
for a while until i moved to london and
then
i did date like white guys here a little
bit i was in like two um
interracial relationships one was three
years
the next one was
maybe a year and
i don't really know why i stopped it was
just kind of like
yeah i think it was like around black
lives matter and that made me kind of
think and reflect on my to myself like
what am i doing and
i want black love really okay
do you think it matters in 2022
who you're dating does it matter the
race of a person that you're dating
yeah it does lead to problems because
i've dated black as well and even though
i'm a mixed race person so i'm just as
black as i am asian but the reality is
sight sees me as black
it matters because you're going to have
cultural likenesses and when you marry
someone you marry into their family so
if you're looking at say
i don't know a more secular culture like
arab culture which is closely aligned
with islam
if you're
i don't know say
a christian african it's less likely
that your cultures are going to align
um i know you have your opinions on
islam in itself so that within
marrying up with the black culture you
can see how there'll be def there'll be
different likenesses that wouldn't
necessarily go
um but it all depends how
individualistic and collective this you
see yourself are you marrying a family
are you just marrying her and just
living in that bubble of your love for
them
ladies does it matter in 2022
that you date outside of your race um
in a way
okay it depends what you what do you
mean by like metal does it matter does
it matter does it matter to you does it
matter to general society
um to general society i feel like
there's a lot of apps that push the
interracial
date in and i'm not saying it's a
negative thing or a positive thing i
just see that that's highlighted a lot
um
but in ways like i can agree with you
and say when you say like with cultures
it does make things easier when you date
the same culture because
it's not something that's new but if you
are going to date outside your culture
you have to be willing to learn
that that race
yeah that's a good part of the reason
why i stopped doing interracial
relationships because the cultural clash
was like too
what was the like cultural clash that
like made your relationship hard um it
was things just like
a food wise my food was always too spicy
okay
um your food was too spicy what wait
what
me talking on um he was white okay and i
was doing he had too spicy a food yeah
okay and i was dating i was actually
done he made spicy food yeah that's my
food oh okay i was actually dating a
white guy around like the whole black
lives matter movement right and so i had
always had a lot to say on that and he
was always like you're always talking
about black lives matter like why and i
was like because it's going on currently
even though he had a hand power sticker
outside of his window just didn't like
me talking about does it change um
anything like now in hindsight now that
like the whole organization has come out
as a scam
um
what do you mean sorry black lives
matter yeah like they're in hot water
right now you haven't heard i didn't
hear about that yeah the organ is like
the oh they found out the the leader of
the black lives matter was like keeping
the money and not even giving it to the
victims paying for like a really
expensive yeah and saying that it was um
a business class her mansion that she
lived in and like through parties
yeah yeah and like like so i'm i'm just
curious in hindsight now is it different
because
you're talking really not really because
like the black lives matter movement for
me goes past that woman okay completely
uh-huh so it hasn't really changed for
me okay
but yeah i don't agree with what she did
goku as you were gonna say something
no i was just no no i was just curious
because um it just seems like if that
was a big issue in your relationship
like it would be less of like hindsight
being 20 20 like knowing that that was a
scam maybe it would be less of an issue
now that was my thought yeah i'm also
quite a historical person so i just like
to bring up the history a lot i like to
watch a lot of films and things like
that and and i realized that that made
him uncomfortable a lot of the time he
was like why do you always bring this
because it's just things that i'm into
and i like to talk about and i want
someone who's like-minded to have these
questions
so it kind of sounds like you just
wanted someone that more like
politically that aligned with you yeah
so would you say it was more politics
rather than like skin color um
because if you were dating a guy that
like was white and he didn't have an
issue with you talking about it all the
time then it maybe it would have been a
different result yeah
but i still yeah
yeah
i still would prefer to date i think are
you more attracted to black guys yeah
okay yeah so it's like preference
you're more attracted to black guys now
or were you all were you always more
attracted to i think
i became more attracted to black guys
when i moved to london i didn't have i
didn't grow up in a i went to
a predominantly white school
predominantly white college um my uni
when i moved to london was in north west
london like you know what northwest
london is like um
sorry are you attracted to them more now
because you see yourself more in them
now yeah
i'm telling you there was a lot of
self-hatred growing up because like i
said i was labeled as a coconut at from
a young age for the music i was into for
the taste i liked you know just people
don't always align so many things with
being black
that's one of the things i find just to
say that like people think that black is
one monolith thing yeah you know what i
mean and it's like you know black people
can't be conservative black people can't
support trump or black
think black people need to realize and i
think part of the problem why people
have such
a problem with interracial relationships
i've always said as a person you can
love who you want to love do what you
want to do
um i think when people generally i can't
tell people
how to live their life and how to love
like and i don't put myself in a
position to do that to anyone but i
think one of the reasons why a lot of
black people have a problem with um
interracial relationships because we
believe that we're one thing
like we believe that there's a textbook
of stuff that you've got a tick to be
black
can you give some examples like black
people uh black people can't swim black
people don't swim uh black people
um like seriously this is some of the
things you hear like uh
what else uh black people wouldn't have
voted for trump
right
but they do but they did he got the
largest percentage of the black vote
from any president in like a really long
time that was a republican hmm
um
so
being black also means white people
can't do your hair
like as a
there's a ballpark like we had a big
conversation the day is it's the food is
too spicy
or it smells
when you're in the office it's
wait when you say hey do you mean like
they can't like copy your hairstyle no
as in like they can't clean your hair
you can't you can't you definitely 100
percent can't go to most hairdressers in
this country oh yeah like like yeah 99
will just they'll turn you yeah but do
you see
but how does that factor into like
interracial relationships so like your
child
like they're not going to comb their
hair they're not going to know how to
moisturize it shampoo it condition it
they might not know about shampoo or
conditioner you know do you not think
that's something that can be learned
it is i would hope that if like
someone's having an interracial kid they
would be willing to go above and beyond
to learn that for their child that's the
hope yeah
just go to a primary school and you will
see
you will see otherwise you can just look
at how the children rock up to school
but i think isn't that
more that person's choice or suitable
candidate because i can talk for me i'm
half asian even though i identify as
black
and growing up my mom went the extra
mile like she knew how to do my sister's
hair she knew how to cook your life she
so isn't that your choice
and a suitable partner rather than them
being off that race in terms of the
aspects you're speaking of true no
definitely
that's a huge part of it and i think
that's one of the reasons why we have
the stigma at least with black men at
the moment because i feel like a lot of
black men haven't picked great partners
yeah equally i i also think that they
haven't necessarily had a choice
um we live in a world where
you know
at the end of the day women have a
choice on whether
they keep the child or not whether they
send it to a adoption or not how do men
not have a choice and their partners
that's not they just did it no no no
it's more a case of like
they're not the first
if it's the first person you've ever had
sex with and then you have a child with
them understandable but if they're not
the first person that means you you
you've done it before
you you know about condoms there's
female condoms
there's contraception for both men and
women
if you don't use any of that and then
you now come to a point where you're
pregnant
and you don't you have a conversation
with your partner you don't have a
conversation with your partner
then if you don't have a conversation
you're not giving a person a choice of
whether they're in that child's life or
not or if that child comes to the world
you just lost me a little bit there okay
so
you said that that men or black men
often don't have a choice and who who
they date
no no or who they make a baby with no
what i guess what i mean by that is
the point
the kind of people a lot of black men
have chosen wrong yeah the kind of point
made is that you've not necessarily
chosen the best partner but the point
i'm trying to make is most people aren't
necessarily choosing their partner
they're having sex with people and then
ending up with children oh so they're
making the choice to be irresponsible
they're making the choice to have sex
and do it irresponsibly but both parties
yeah but yeah so they're not thinking
about bringing a child into this world
who's going to grow up and have issues
with like their hair texture or where
they're living yeah so they're not even
going to go
yeah
yeah they're not making that choice it's
just bad man procreation yeah
i think i think i think where i'm seeing
is as you're saying they're making a
choice to be irresponsible but
ultimately whether the child is born is
down to the woman is the point he's
trying to make he does he does once
the sperm has left it's down to the
woman if she doesn't want to have that
child she won't have that job all right
it's much more on the woman yeah because
we have we have the option of birth
control we have the option of abortion
like we we have all these choices where
men men don't abortion is the main one
yet yeah yeah but at the same time like
he still made a choice to not wear a car
to not work condom knowing the
consequences yeah yeah yeah so when it
comes to racial relationships do you
think that it's
mostly
black men that choose to date outside
their race no
no at all what country lady oh look you
said ooh what country are you talking
about though because in the western
world because you're talking
statistically in the in in the uk i wish
i could fight i can't find it i've got
if you let me get my phone i can send
you i think that you know that'd be
great yeah you can you can look it up
in my opinion more black men date
outside of their race than black women
just gonna say that and okay i can tell
you the stats in the u.s it's like 85
percent of black men um date in their
race but it go ups to 30 percent date
out when they make over a certain amount
of money yeah that sounds about right
you see them at nfl stars yeah yeah so
it's like if they make a certain amount
of money it ups to 30 why do you think
that is
why do i think that yeah why why when it
gets to that
tax bracket did they date well to me
it's like because um in the u.s at least
i have no idea what the stats are here
but i think when men get money they want
a pretty little skinny thing and like
they want they want the hot chick and
and statistically black women in the u.s
are more obese than other races
so like to me it's just more of them
aren't in shape you don't think it's a
racing you think it may be a shape thing
yeah
[Music]
what do you think ladies i don't think
it's a shape thing i just feel like
i don't want to say like
i'm saying say it say it
because no i need to word it correctly
it's just like when you start getting
higher up with the hierarchy in terms of
like the ceos and people like that you
start to see less and less black women
so the black men who are in that
hierarchy they're obviously going to
date outside of their race because
there's less black women generally
but then don't
aren't black women more educated than
black men in the western world so they
would be more but i think in that
hierarchy underlooked so they're not
necessarily the ones who are going to be
promoted
education i don't i thought they were
the most enrolled i don't think they're
the most sorry the most enrolled yeah
yeah
yeah i don't think education dictates
class
yeah that's the thing and and i don't
think men really care that much about
education
like again like when i talk to men they
tell me they want fit feminine friendly
it's like those three things
and so to me education is just like a
shoe collection to us it's like nothing
yeah but if you say she if she says she
got a fat ass they're like who
it just seems like it's more of like a
in shape thing so so we're going to uni
for nothing then
now you're going to uni for you
yeah
where he actually says the trend has
actually
flipped within this century that
women are actually becoming more
educated than men in terms of
relationships and the average
relationship
they're saying so they're actually going
to seek higher education over men that
doesn't necessarily
lean over to pay because some men may
leave school straight away and go learn
a trade or may be a recruiter while
women go and work in education right
because well women don't pick industries
that make a lot of money we pick easier
jobs than men that's what jordan
peterson talks about that's why
he he believes the
pay gap is yeah he doesn't actually
exist it doesn't exist no it doesn't
no because like we don't pick plumbing
bricklaying like any of the garbage men
do you know do you know i've actually
heard that when it comes to internet
relationships because we were talking
about black men i've heard of
many black women when they see talking
about that 30 that you were just talking
about that day out pearl i've heard many
black women say oh look at him he's sold
out
he's now gone with a becky blah blah
blah
why is it becky why can't it be like
rebecca
i don't even i don't even know what
becky is
are black women salty like when black
men day out
and why yes to an extent yeah i feel
like we only talk about the ones who
uh what's the word hmm
sold out yeah
what does selling out mean now like what
is that you'll date outside of your race
and then you will come and cuss out the
black women um in your race within your
own race
like your mother is black i don't
understand
i don't think it's a problem to date
outside of your race as a black man i
think you should date whoever you want
to date but then don't come and like
condemn the black women and say you have
brought you up supposedly let's say
i don't understand that i actually and
saying you're too stubborn you're two
days you're too that so your
justification for dating outside of your
race is basically because other races
are easier or won't put up with your
[ __ ]
do you think that do you think other
races are easier of women
i personally don't but
from i want to hear from the men that
they did with black men that's what i
hear so yeah it would be interesting to
hear from you guys like what you
actually think as you say that i do want
to ask her because you've dated both
white men you're attracted to black men
now i don't know if you've dated black
men as since you've been becoming black
men so then would you say white men are
easier would you say black men are
easier
what's your kind of
uh
if i had to answer honestly honestly
no man is easy to be honest like
it doesn't
for me
he's still got a penis here oh it's
still a headache
yeah that's i don't view it i never
viewed it that way okay
so to the black man have you dated both
white men and black women that's white
men sorry white women and black women
i've never dated a white woman no yeah i
haven't dated a white woman okay do you
think that it's easier to date a black
woman
then it is someone that's non-black
non-black is almost like that word of
being
why we're not using asian
white i feel like i'd say when you're
talking like asian arabs or sorry to cut
you off yeah or east or even southern or
east asians it's more not to do with
them because
the ethnic minorities are in the uk
they're dealing with it's more the
families that you're going to deal with
right so they're governed by certain
cultures or certain religions where it
makes it less likely so it's not more
them because they understand what it's
like to be marginalized and be a
minority group even though we're a
different struggle it's enough to draw
likenesses
but
asian families and this is me saying as
an asian man a half asian man a lot of
asian families are racist towards blacks
because of the colonial ideas put upon
him right so that does seep through so
you have to deal with that not everyone
is forward thinking
because kevin samuels
rest in power kevin
right
he highlighted in america specifically
for me because he would always talk
about black women black women are this
and
this is what black women do and it would
be it would use statistics right and so
what the p the women that generally
phoned into his show
um tended to have a problem with the
fact that he was talking about black
women
um
however the stuff that he was saying
was backed up with statistics and logic
so
there's a thing have you women heard of
a thing called swirling for black women
no
you know how to swirl in it's when black
is when black women say
or divesting
we've got to divest in
right so a lot of black women in america
are saying that they are divesting from
black men and now they are going with
white men
have you heard of that movement there's
a whole movement called that that's a
bird i had a big debate the other day
women say i'm not done with men i'm
going to start dating women so like that
sorry about it you know what's
interesting i feel like if it was the
reverse
like like it
people would freak out like if if um
black men said that about black women
said that they're going to go on day out
they're divesting yeah we're dating like
wouldn't you think it'd be a completely
different reaction yeah because the
feminist movement is a thing and you
know what you know it's like women get
the women get the power to say anything
we're like
yeah we're we're men it's like if they
say the same thing yeah
however there is a man on youtube called
forget his thing he goes to thailand and
he's telling all the black men in
america to go and get his high wife
oh yeah you can't i heard they can like
cut clean like they can do the whole
thing like
if you can afford it i would tell them
to go to
they're probably much better wives there
what
what is your preference says a man black
why anything
um
i
i i like
both i like black and white guys yeah
okay what was your experience dating
between the two day between white and
black
i've only dated black guys
it comes
from black women about dating black guys
yes yeah yeah yeah oh that's interesting
yeah i mean it's mostly not there's only
one time i could think about it that it
happened in person oh my god this girl
was for the streets she was like trying
to like hook up with my boyfriend right
in front it was so weird but but that
was only once like most of it's just
online but yeah we would get like
comments a lot on like pictures and
videos that we would do
would he post you as well yeah and then
like they would they would they were
worse than his comments section i think
than mine to be honest
yeah so what is that black women i feel
like they have what is it
they do have resurrectedness they do
have more energy for the women no i'm
just asking like what is it
no i'm just asking what is that that
that hate or that ill feeling towards
white women with black men what is it
where does it come from
well i wouldn't be in a position to talk
about because i don't feel that way for
me i'm just very open and general about
love like
you're you're free you're free
everyone's free to date who they want to
date and i do understand that well i do
recognize that some white women face
like a different struggle when they're
dating black men
but it's not something that i understand
hold on don't lie now
that's your captain it's your captain
right now yeah like because in my head
i'm thinking about this one time i was
talking to some people and they said ah
if he likes dating white women he can
just keep doing it
you don't remember that
um ah
damn personally i just turned my head
and mind my business today
because like if from someone that's been
in relation racial relationships i don't
really feel like i'm someone to speak on
oh you can't date so and so i have a
problem when it comes to fetishization
of black men
oh what's that
yes
you know like
oh he's got a bbc you know
these conversations do happen
but
yeah you know things like that i haven't
an issue with that or when white men
fetishize black women like guys have
said to me white men have said to me oh
you you're so um exotic exotic and then
the chocolate coming out
that's what i have an issue with so
question like if a guy said something
because i'm trying to think of like if i
was in your shoes and someone said to me
like vanilla like i wouldn't care
so i'm just curious like why why is that
offensive um it's not offensive but it
happens
oh okay it happens like
there's so much ways that we're feticide
fetishized like i never sorry i never
understand what fetishize means that's
that's more of my question it's like a
crave it's not really like you want to
be with this person
it's just that oh we have these ideas
about them like for example when i went
to so it's like stereotyping almost
stereotyping but just hearing things
about the person not actually wanting to
be with them because you love them it's
because you've heard these different
ideas about them so when i was in spain
oh i see okay i was in spain so what
you're trying to say is that they think
black men have got a big well let me see
i was in spain
and there was this white man that
followed me continuously like it was at
a festival he would be he would be
festival the beach constantly following
me asking me if i could sleep with him
and then i never realized until my
cousins was like it's that idea that
they have some men have their that black
women are easy and they're easy to sleep
with so
but however in europe there's a lot of
um
black women that come from
africa and become prostitutes when i was
in portugal i saw the same thing yeah
and i'm not one of them right but that's
probably that could be one of the
reasons why they were following around
they probably thought you were a
prostitute
i'm just saying absolutely
yeah
oh you're you acting like you were
enjoying the attention i wasn't enjoying
the attention i just said it was an
issue
okay just name facts okay thanks
when it comes to um because piggybacking
off the back of that right so when it
comes to like
do you think black men are more desired
than other men
there was a and i say that because there
was a controversial poll online
where it said that the least desired man
when it comes to the dating market is an
asian man yes i heard that east asian
man
well dating app data um
yeah it's like indian i'm pretty sure
but no number one is white number two is
black um but black is like
moving up according to like dating app
data oh wow because that's how you can
get the most honest feedback you know
what it is for women the most desired i
want to see if you guys guess it
for women yeah the most desires yeah
like the most swept right now to south
american women
that's weird it's asian
the most desired women in asian like
they're the most swiped right on on
dating apps elsewhere do you know who
the least swept black
black women yeah
because because there was there was an
article i was reading i think it was on
vice and they were saying um you know
racism shows itself in the dayton app
market but i don't think it's
necessarily racism i just think people
have got preferences
i mean i think it goes back to like size
at least in the us
size yeah
no no like like again black women are
more obese in the u.s
no i don't think it's that because at a
certain point
i think i don't know about you guys but
i like i like my woman to have some
features on them that you know show
they're a woman so
what does that mean right but like by
and large you're an exception you're not
the rule like you you might you may
prefer like curvier or bigger women but
like by and large when a man gets money
what does he do
he gets a bad little like model
he doesn't go and get lizzo yeah
i'm not saying that my
my type is like super curvy yeah i guess
more to what your type is super curvy
women no
um more to my point is that it's about
liking a woman i feel like as a black
guy like a woman who has features like
when i think about what i like to do
whether it's salsa whether i'm at
carnival
you know i want someone who's able to
move who can who can move their hips
they need to have hips to kind of do
that you know it's things like that
where
to be honest i just that's what i'm i'm
kind of thinking of so if i'm on a
dating app or if when i was
past tense
um
i don't know i felt like
sometimes black women wouldn't really
reply you know
at a certain point
it's like you you swipe on who you feel
like you'd get a response from it's no
longer about
you know what what you like because
on on dating that's for sure one what
you like does not always swipe back so
it's a bit over when they
why do you think they wouldn't reply
no girls don't reply most of the time
like it does it doesn't really matter
like
maybe it's just me maybe i was a bit
unfortunate and i'm i'm not i'm not that
well endowed in the facial features
but honestly
this is a family show
no honest but yeah no they they normally
don't really reply to too tough and i
would come with some spicy lines you
know what i'm saying but it's
really a game yeah yo i'm telling you
i can drop game man
but no
it didn't really matter why i did or
said
um
sometimes you just wouldn't get nothing
back um and even if you did it wouldn't
go nowhere
so
sorry go pro oh no no
do you find that you um
are approached by women and if they are
are they
black are they white are they other
do you know what i've been approached
more since i've been in a relationship
and it's jarring but it's more black
women now don't let the girlfriend say
this is a bit it's a bit i am here
yeah yeah
yeah
oh
i didn't know
so yeah i think i've been approached
more recently and it's just i find it
strange as well because sometimes she's
right next like we just kissed and
they're still trying to approach me it's
crazy but that's black women we haven't
no white women has approached me oh no
no some girls just have the audacity
yeah
they do not care yeah
but it's it's because it goes back to
like biology it's pre-selection
it's like women like why like why do
women say men are trash because they're
all sleeping with the same ones right
not not saying he is but um
but when they see like that another girl
selected select selected him and makes
him more attractive to them because
women were biologically predispositioned
to like a man that other girls like
yeah
competition anxiety yeah the fear of
missing out yeah
yeah it's kind of messed up but if you
look at it it's interesting because if
you look at dating app data it's like
between five and twenty percent of men
get all the likes
and if you ask what do those men look
like though like what's their aesthetic
what is it that they're bringing
why the women always a good picture is
hot yeah tall i mean if you see the
filters that women put on it's like six
two and up
and it's down like bumble and stuff
she's smiling she knows
yeah and so and you know what percent of
men are over six foot
fifteen percent
so if you want a black guy that's over
six foot what what percentage do you
think that is of men
and you want him to earn a certain
amount yeah and then pick connect and
let's and let's say let's say you want
to make over 70k or maybe let's do 60
cakes we're in the uk
but
what percent of men do you think that is
0.5
it keeps going down
so there's two of those guys in london
probably
there's probably more
yeah i actually i don't know the
percentage off the top of my head but
but i would guess it's less than five
percent probably less than two percent
and you've got to think those guys have
got options so now you've got to look at
yourself are you the superstar that he's
going to be picking out of his abundance
of options yeah that's a difficult to
swallow that you might be attending your
head but not in your waist
okay
do you guys think like um
when it comes to interracial like white
men are desired by
black women
now because i've see i've seen like more
black women with white men now one thing
i would say from black
growing up a teen i grew up between an
ethnically diverse area with
my dad not with my mom and then and not
necessarily the diverse area of my dad
and it
in certain pockets of essex like when i
went to visit my dad i'm seeing that
there was a generation of black men just
hating on black women that they actually
became so revolted that they went to the
other side because they're just like
well you are just going to call us like
drug buzzers say that we look like
gorillas these are actually showing us
love so it's almost like in certain
pockets the black man has pushed a black
woman away when the black woman has
actually been
loyal to a point and then eventually
gets the point of like well we're going
to date someone
did you see that
that guy the other day that was on that
went viral for that and he called the
black woman yeah that's why that's what
i said the comment we did um a tick tock
duet on it and that his viewpoint
as a mixed race man is a view of many of
people in like certain pockets of essex
of that time right because that's what
pushed what was the social norms in
their areas is like
blonde blue eyes brunette busty tits
fake lips and ironically now it's even
getting closer to black features
everything is black features apart from
actually being black
um
do you find that men want to actually
wife those girls because i from what
i've seen the girls that have like the
botox lips and like that look suit with
the fake tits like they'll screw them
for a night but a mother of their kids
wife um doesn't but that's that's where
where i think the modern woman gets it
lost she's when she goes out in a night
out
the man's giving all the attention to
them kind of women because he wants to
chop them for a night you're in the club
to chop you're not in a club to find a
future wife yeah and then her head gets
[ __ ] up because she's almost natural
oh men aren't into me but just in this
setting in this time
i know the amanda when we go out if
they're going ibiza
they're not looking for
a bible with the bible going natural
they're looking for this skimpiest g
string and they're trying to bust their
cheeks open as quick as possible yeah so
it's just like you need to look at the
settings you're in and then apply logic
to that
that's interesting just to touch on that
so you think um i'm sorry that's why
i've said that
you know men go to strip clubs
because they want to look at women that
look like that but they don't want to
necessarily work with me like that and i
think like you just said i think women
of that this generation because men have
shown
that type of woman so much attention
they're kind of getting it twisted and
they think oh i need to look like that
to get attention now and it's like no
don't do that yeah don't do that that's
just like that's just what we do when we
feel a little bit i don't know whatever
i know men body count or triple figures
and they're like
you know what a wife this girl she's a
reaver she's into islam she don't have
social media she don't go out she's
i'm like the only guys he's ever slept
with and that's who they end up with i'm
saying
but they've gone and done whatever
they've done you know
why do you guys think
when they're talking about interracial
relationships it's always like black and
white like you never hear people talk
about asian and white
or
or like asian and black like it's always
black and white it's the most divisive
why because of the history between black
blacks and whites being oppressed it's
the most divisive all the
semantic words we have behind it it's
almost like that's the reason why when
even when you look at
white and black culture probably
has
more things that are analogous than say
black and arab
like a lot of if you're black and
non-muslim you're probably going to have
less likelihood arab muslim than you are
with say the average white person well
the arabs were like
really like really worse
no no they're like they castrated the
men yeah so they couldn't breed the
women
yeah so so like why do like we don't
really hear about that though so why is
one more divisive than the other it's
loud if you look at america ruled the
world so i think americans at that time
even though they're not the natives but
americans were seen as white so that's
why
that's probably why we talk about it now
i think they just they just mashed up
the whole information chain on that one
because you don't learn that in school i
had to look online for that stuff no
that
oh god no i read um
thomas sowell has a book on it and it's
oh god yes when they they talked about
the arab slave trade oh it's it's it's
westerny i would say expressed
it's the worst oh my god i was scarred
after like reading the account oh my
gosh
it's like when they they had the slaves
have to walk across the desert and it
was like over 50 of them died in the
walk and then the guys that made it
would get castrated
like they were known for being like like
gruesome all across the world and that's
the thing it's like we were talking
earlier on about culture
i think
people within the west generally have a
similar culture that they can
that they can try and gravitate towards
like a general culture if that makes
sense and then
what happens is when another culture
comes in it's worse because it's like i
would say i'm more likely to marry a
white woman than i am an arab
i'd agree with you you know what i'm
saying
i'm more likely to marry a uh
a white woman than it is a someone from
pakistan
and it's because there's a similar
culture there like when as i said when
you go into that culture
no you don't you there's nothing of like
there's no similarities
if anything you're probably
and a lot of their cultures maybe their
first generation has changed but when
you're looking at from over there they
have a car system against their own
right you remember as a black you are
the bottom of the bottom yeah if they're
putting other asians who are darker
skinned because obviously looking at the
history of when you say look at india if
you're darker skinned you as a worker
if you're light-skinned you was in the
house
so when you're looking at bringing the
black people into even when you look at
gandhi before he did his whole change
and did what he did for india he was an
avid racist when he was studying in
south africa he said
um the most barbaric human is a
darker-skinned man then it's indians and
then it's wax and then it's only
switched it around and that's gandhi who
is like the
most peaceful man ever to live yeah but
he was announced but that's another
one
for another day i'm going to read super
chats really quick um
let me just refresh them
guys if you want if you have a comment
you want red to send a super chat and we
will read it
um so survivor survival of the sim
simping the original sin is what started
all these issues until that this is
addressed and men attach their god
energy masculinity these issues will
continue man plus masculinity plus man
equals god women plus femininity equals
goddess i'm dragon stallion one zero
zero one
something else why black women in the us
don't get chosen to wife up 95 percent
of blacks vote democrats which doesn't
lead to traditional conservative family
values um and and nico see men who date
based on high volume high rejection will
encounter more non-black women and
blacks are four percent of the
population
black women are two percent
um richard schaffmann is it better to
sigma to be a sigma male than an alpha
male i don't think yeah what's a sigma
mil sorry
is that relevant
you know what we're just gonna
um uh mosey moza 2006 thank you for the
super chat
sierra pierre jerome i'm an engineer
i've tried to date black women but they
don't want me they want me to wait until
they are ready and used up and i won't
accept it when i date other races i'm
more accepted and appreciated
something to watch most black women have
huge
egos and die alone um red cowa
um the norm for black women
um that's crazy the norm for black women
is being rude and we don't want that
alan stinger you all don't want them
anyway because they're lame for example
a nuclear physicist got rejected by the
a hawks cheerleader and yes
um
black women in this generation are rude
as hell he's upset
here in america interracial dating is
looked down upon for black men
especially if he's successful is it the
same in europe meanwhile our vp and
serena williams have white husbands and
it is cheered um
the savvy ninja to find a black woman
who is in shape in the u.s is like 1 in
15 my guess i don't do drama and black
women who have fully embraced the drama
but as a whole it is sad but true
something to watch black guys and black
guy in the white
i'm not reading that um
no
i'm not reading that no read it if it's
not cursing me not read it no read it
read it um black guy and the white and
pearl should hook up
okay passionate rebellion just because
one woman who is a decentralized
organization called black lives matter
was a scammer doesn't mean the whole
movement was a scam cereal real if you
date a mixed-race person as a black
person does that count as interracial or
is that oh that's interesting or does
that count as something else ariel lewis
just married
in may to my first choice who happens to
be white i'm black by the way we match
all of our core values and we literally
talk about everything especially
stereotypes and racial topics i'm going
to refresh the page just to see if
there's any more
um
let's see
okay yeah there's a couple um snuggle
668 drop the link so we can talk to
everybody
um and then that's the simping one okay
those are all the super chats
oh right there was a lot said in there
um
black women didn't seem to be getting a
good rep in there ladies so why did you
think it's that it's already going daily
can i say one thing sir um i can only is
the u.s thing that they could keep
talking about is being in shape but this
is more question to you guys in the uk
i unless you're an auntie i don't know
loads of black women that are out of
shape like that i genuinely would say
it's more or less the same across all
the races that's my experience i don't
know what you guys think
i feel like people in the uk are more in
shape like in general
i mean the u.s has got some obesity
yeah i've been to u.s a few times and
i've never seen people that big the
obesity problem is like an epidemic like
are they talking about people that are
like morbid and saying do you know like
basically in the 90s um the government
for example mcdonald's used to sell the
same size burgers as they do in america
in the 90s and the government saw that
there was an epidemic of obesity so they
cut down all the portion size of food in
general so then we stopped having that
problem as
large as the us still have it
oh so we could have had it so we could
have had it but the government kind of
said no i feel like we might have it
yeah people are still trying to find a
way to do it in this country like
obesity has been on the rise since but
more so that's a choice isn't it that
it's really been put into your own hands
as opposed to something that is just
your environment um yeah
so why would black women get such a bad
rep in the super chats ladies so we're
going angry and loud is what i heard you
are part of the problem because you're
putting us in a box in stereotyping me
no not you but whoever's making those
comments thank you because you're not
helping this so you don't see that no i
don't believe that you should stereotype
i'm tired of that narrative that all
black women are loud and angry and
barren
and you're always so mad because it's
not true
yeah you can't generalize your
individual experience
until you've experienced every single
black woman you can't just
throw out these comments unless you you
say oh that's my experience with black
women
so i feel like there's truth to it
it's wondering i was wondering when
someone's going to say it all
stereotypes coming from a little bit of
truth from somewhere but i think
in this context i don't agree with the
comments i just think
potentially those comments come from the
way we're portraying let's say in the
media and like films even to the point
where like on netflix what do we have we
have like a whole black lives matter
collection i hate that it's just like
slave films things like that i don't
understand do you know who else doesn't
help the stereotypes he's those
comedians that put on the wigs and take
the piss out of black women yeah they do
not help
um so i have a question
so on my tick tock the other day i did a
um a tick tock with my friend she's a
housewife okay
and i i put the video and i said um show
me your ring and it's like this big fat
ring right and i i said what do you do
for a living she says i love my husband
basically and i said how did you get to
the point was that was that you yeah
oh no way i saw that video okay okay and
she said i love my husband and like i
said okay a lot of girls want to know
like how how did you get to this point
and she says well i became a better
person i learned to be submissive and in
the comments section um the
it was a lot of like black women that
were
commenting saying that they could not
submit and like like having an issue
with submission
um and so i'm curious like how you guys
feel about submission
my initial thought when i saw that video
was like
you know you do you but that's not for
me you know but that's for someone by
yeah what do you mean it's not for you
why why is it not for you i mean because
different strokes for different folks if
she chooses to submit and that's who she
wants to be then that's so you have a
problem with submission
um
no
in my own life i'm i wouldn't say i'm
much of a submissive girl so for me that
wouldn't be how i would choose to
live my life but if she wants to do that
then she don't want to get married
and be being submissive i i don't think
that me not being submissive is going to
stop me from getting married i think it
makes it harder because the the
masculine men like they want to lead
yeah and so if you're like so when
you're submitting you're saying like i
trust you with the big decisions i trust
you to lead yeah and so i think unless
you would prefer a guy that follows
which
to me as a woman is like a turn off
um it's not a case that i don't want to
submit by the way it's probably just a
case of i haven't found the right person
i want to submit to well i don't i think
it's kind of either you're submissive or
you're not as a person probably not then
yeah that's
that's because because um
like i i don't because to me it being
submissive pairs with the trait
agreeableness yeah and it's it's paired
with like being able to follow someone
um so i think it's more of a personality
trait go on over sorry you just came
well
sorry got tagged in there i don't think
you can disagree with the super chat so
then say oh i don't want to be
submissive to my man because think about
this way yeah if i was to say i was
gonna be conditionally masculine so i'ma
dress like a girl and say ah yeah are
you saying babes and then i'll be like
wait i can only be masculine when you
make me feel that way that doesn't make
no sense so think about what you're
saying no let me tell you how i was
raised so i grew up in a house of um
eight girls
one brother he's super young so my dad
always taught us to be like really
independent and i think i've just been
like independent by default and growing
up with that mindset there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with that and i
think that that's right but at the same
time if you're looking for a man and for
most women they want a masculine man who
can hold the thought down so unless
you're willing to submit to a man
naturally you have to go for the
opposite which is amanda submissive i
think i just hate that word submissive
to be honest with you what does it mean
to you
for me personally i get like some
negative sort of what does it mean
though
it almost feels to
bend
and you know do whatever he says yeah
let your man have the the reigns of the
the relationship and
that's what it feels like to me it is
you relinquish control and i don't yeah
i'm a bit of a control freak where you
know
but it's interesting because um when i
like i i talk to
like a lot of black guys follow this
account and a common complaint i hear
with them with black women is they feel
like they can't submit to them
i feel like black women don't want to
submit those yeah
they're afraid that if they submit
that black man is still going to turn
around and uh go for someone in a
different race and then talk [ __ ] about
them
i don't know oh so there's a fear of
that yeah i i i there's that as well
because when i hear submission i feel
like what i'd i'd never want to do that
but from having a conversation the other
day it's kind of changed my mind on
submission it's more like
like what you were saying allowing a man
to be a man and like walk in his
masculine energy and
you being submissiveness not necessarily
you
uh losing all control is sort of like
you being able to sit in your feminine
energy and to be soft and to allow and
accept and then allow the man to lead
and con not to control but like to
direct
have you ever had a guy
um plan a date but make you plan it be
like what do you want to eat yeah where
do you want to go absolutely or have you
had a guy say okay i'm picking you up at
six this is where we're going
be ready this is the dress code which
which one's more attractive the second
one
yeah
what's the
that likes to pick the problem because i
am a control freak like that oh you want
to pick the restaurant
sometimes i'm the sort of hard friend is
that because it's out of ease
not because it's the better option
i don't know i feel like my mind is
getting more at ease if i get to control
the situation feminine men a little bit
because i just can't imagine a masculine
man like letting that slide to be honest
so it would almost and you're and you're
also saying that maybe i've definitely
been with masculine men i think i've
just like had you let go put my foot
down to be honest with you come on you
put your foot down
away not with me you better slow down
we've been with guys who i can have my
way with very easily yeah yeah
that's what you're saying because that's
feminine it is a truly a truly masculine
man isn't gonna put up with that
he's just gonna be like this is too much
of a headache let me move on to the next
one
especially because there's a lack of
masculinity in the society so the guys
that are actually masculine they get
hella [ __ ] 100
and the thing is because we're applying
gender to the conversation but masculine
and feminine doesn't just exist to like
a heterosexual relationship if you look
at lesbians when you look at gay people
there's always someone who's a top or
bottom or masculine feminine fem stem
there's never two masculine women
there's always a masculine and feminine
so it causes too many arguments when
you've been too
so if you're saying that you're the
agreeable one you're just the one
wearing the trousers of actually
admitting you're the one wearing the
trousers but you're the one steering the
[ __ ] but then also in the context of
interracial relationships you can start
to see now where in some context some
conversations where you'd see that black
men deviate
out of
dating black women because if this is
perspective that the average black woman
carries
and you're defending that statement and
we're talking about true masculinity and
how men who are masculine don't want to
have to part with that it's easy to see
how he's gonna be like you know what
even if i like black women i don't want
that kind of headache so i'm gonna go
for someone else who's not gonna give me
that sort of trouble i wouldn't call it
a headache that's a headache trust me
that's because you're not on the
receiving end of it yeah i actually
understand that
like i really understand that the thing
about submission though it's not
something that every woman is born with
like you have to learn and i don't know
if it's the man that teaches you or the
man that you're with and the man that
you choose that teaches you or you
actually have to see that within
yourself i know that in my experience i
had to see that within myself because i
came in this and i wanted to lead
everything like everything
did you have both parents in your home
no i didn't but i had i had my mom and
my stepdad okay and did your stepdad
come in like later or later on yeah and
so i i find that a lot of people that
don't naturally know how to submit they
didn't have that example growing up
of like um a masculine father and the
mother following him or if they did
maybe it was kind of one of those like
relationships where the mom is kind of
like blue ball or what do they say live
on youtube
you hit my parents relationship around
the head my mom is very much the leader
in my parents marriage like my dad is
the quiet you know how do you think that
works out for society though generally
to have women leading the households of
men
do you think that's a good thing or a
bad thing in some cases it is because i
can't sit here and say that mom's been a
bad leader she's been a very very good
leader and the thing even though my
experience was that and it it does touch
on what you've said
i still went out and chose someone you
guys would classify as masculine because
and the reason why is because you know
we're talking about the black community
about so black community have like
60 to 70 to up to 74 single mothers
right
and when they have like boys
a lot of the boys like there's a there's
a single parent to prison pipeline that
just can't be denied do you know what i
mean and so
a lot of the time both the women
so both the boys go to jail and a lot of
the girls
end up quite promiscuous like they do
you know what i mean and so that father
in the house is really needed it's
necessary
um so i have a question for you you said
um one of your fears um in being
submissive is that the guy will leave
you and then go talk [ __ ] about your
race or about like black girls is that
what you said
why why are women afraid when they leave
most of the time between 70 to 80 and 90
if they're college educated
wait
so women women women and this is
something i hear a lot it's not just you
but i always hear women like afraid of
being left so in your case it's being
left for a white girl but i've also
heard women being afraid of getting
married and being left for a younger
model or you know someone else but it's
not women who are it's not men who are
leaving it's women
so women leave 70 to 80 of the time if
you're college educated it goes up to 90
so why as women do we have this fear
when we're the ones that are breaking up
our own homes
got him daddy
that was a tumbleweed moment isn't it
let me just let me process it yeah
basically yeah women are the ones
leaving relationships um so for you to
be fearful
of a man leaving you you're more likely
to leave him
statistically yeah so to have that fear
is that level of control that you were
like talking about like he's like you
want total control of the whole
situation like you want to control
whether he's going to leave he's going
to leave i'm going i want i want to be
the one to leave and if he does leave he
can't leave before a white girl
yeah like what like what if what if um
like black men said that so they said i
won't get into a relationship with black
women because i'm afraid they're going
to leave me before a white guy
you know this guy's a waste man
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think i was just like generalizing
yeah why black women might feel that way
that's what i'm struggling to answer
because i don't necessarily feel that
way okay so okay but you've heard it yes
right
literally generalizing so i could be
wrong but
piggybacking off the back of that sorrow
it also you often hear a woman will say
i'm scared to submit to my man to say to
be a housewife just in case
he's the one that leaves and then i'm
left with nothing financially but
when
the majority of women are hypergamous so
they date up or across social socially
economically
generally speaking it's usually the man
that would end up being financially
worse off so i don't see where
fair enough if you're like from saudi
arabia where there's the the divorce
laws aren't 50 50 and you are if you
become a housewife you're at the man's
win but in the western world where
pretty much every western country is 50
50. it's usually the man that
financially falls out so why are men
not apprehensive of that but women are
can i can i address something right
and there's no white men here though it
will be interesting if there's a white
man here um
there's three black guys here i don't
know if you guys have had it but i've
had it right when you've been out with
like white guys
and
they get a little bit of drink in them
and then the jokes turn towards your
penis
have you had that oh bears it's normal
like that's something that i don't get
like when it comes to like the
interracial like just the
the race thing like i don't know it's
like why is my penis on like why are we
talking about my question do you do you
mean you don't get or you don't get
those comments
no i get comments he doesn't understand
i don't understand why
like i'm just wondering when it comes to
like i just think that's a weird thing
to bring up no no because no the reason
why is i i'll kind of like um
level it out because the fetishization
who talked about fetishization
before right of like black and white and
i'm wondering do
is there a stigma with
black men and that
you know i mean and it's not just within
white women but it's also within white
men i don't know
does that make sense yeah again i'm not
like upset at that stigma if that makes
sense
but i think that's not a big thing i
think that's more historical though
because even like if you look at romans
like they saw big penises as barbaric
and over time that's been
changed and so like
it's it's now it's a thing of like
people want that
so maybe that's why they speak about it
because it's a bit a banter of a way to
make themselves feel a bit more
because there's a lot of positive racism
i remember obviously this is slightly
tangible too like growing up when i was
younger i used to i used to go to
academy trials
and then i remember one time i didn't
get the ball and like run past someone
and the coach was just like you're the
quickest person here like why didn't you
show them your pace i'm thinking you've
never seen me run in your life
you've just seen my collar and you've
assumed
so just like when it comes to the
positive racism i think we're less
likely i know as mundane we're less
likely to be like
to make it problem
positive racism i don't think we should
call it that
well it's too hot it's so it's to my
benefit in the fact
when i call it positive racism it's the
fact of
you might now pick me in your academy
because you think i'm quick which is to
my benefit but the whole reason why
you're picking me is actually racist but
it positively benefits me no i just feel
like that's expectations
and having those expectations
generalized across a race just because
of how you look
so i don't think that but that can can
that work in your favor though i'm
saying it positively benefits favor but
i don't think positive is the right word
too well something works in your favor
it's positive it's the same as i think
it's just the two can't go together
because racism is never positive so you
can't just say it's positive
but in that instance it is over here in
that instance it is positive because
he's benefited from the fact that
somebody was racist has discriminated
again against him for his color
but what is it because he could because
they expected him to run fast because
i'm black yeah because he's black it's
not because they expected him to run
fast it's because the reason why that
happened was purely because he's black i
think there's just there's just some
notions that we shouldn't talk about
language but well there's some issues
when you talk about language and
things like racism if you find the right
word
i think then you can like let us know
but i've always i think i think
everyone's waiting on like a few words
yeah i i know we all hear what we're
saying and we all feel what we're saying
because if you root back to racism it's
we've never seen it in a positive light
but now nowadays
um it's just stereotypes
um some people think it's positive but
yeah but i think i think we're getting
lost on something so confident outcomes
yeah um so i have a question for you
guys this is from um poor man poor man's
podcast i'm shout out to you he has some
great content so
um
i want you guys to go around and say if
you think this is true or false
um black men with traditional family
values are rejected and called lames
until women have kids or are approaching
30.
which way do you want to go around first
oh here you can go um i think it depends
on the woman you go for like if you go
through the just in general that not it
depends there's just yes or no it's not
more true or not i'd say no unless the
women you go for like drug dealers when
she's younger okay go ahead um
wait can you read the question again
okay black men with traditional family
values are rejected and called lames
until women have kids or are approaching
30. and a public figure example that i
just came to my head what happened with
sierra
and now um what's her face
no no no the the other girl that also
dated future
um
she had the rappers first and then
michael b jordan then she left him
so
so going around what do you guys um
true but i want to explain a little okay
wait i still need to understand that so
black black men with traditional values
are rejected and called lambs until
women have children or are approaching
30.
so basically like women go for
the bad boys when they're younger and
like maybe um
the not not so traditional men that
really aren't going to be great husbands
or great boyfriends but the bad boys
they're exciting they go for them they
sleep with them then they're then they
either have a kid with them or they're
hitting 30 and they're saying oh [ __ ] i
gotta find i gotta find a man fast so
then they want them and the guys with
traditional values are like salty i see
yeah oh okay that's true yeah i think
it's true then because isn't it the
concept of oh nice guy's always finished
last yeah and then the bad boy is what
you want like the thrill of the
adventure yeah yeah
[Music]
i would say it's somewhat true i'm like
half and half on that comment
okay
um it's facts
[Laughter]
um
i would say
yeah okay so you i feel like you
answered really quickly so what why is
that facts
like what have you seen
um
yeah just from young like
most guys go through this it's like when
you're growing up you've got to fit into
uh to a certain box you have a bad boy
the boy that makes money you're funny
um you got off into a little box in
order to have something about you for
girls to be to be interested in you
me and my boys would talk about how when
i was younger was the nice guy like i
was bare sweet with girls like i'll
treat them nice and when you often ask
girls how they want to be treated
they'll tell you okay this is what i
want when you do those things you're a
waste man like girls do not look at you
they don't want nothing to do with you
so the man who holds those traditional
values when he's younger is is cast
aside the guys that go for when they're
younger are the the guy that stands out
the trapper the boy that makes he's a
trouble in class et cetera et cetera and
then those values are perpetuated as
they grow older and then again the girls
get pregnant or
their body counts are high
and they become
less valuable to the men who become
valuable later in life so they wouldn't
that role reverses and and the men who
were trappers and
bad boys when they were younger end up
in jail war they don't really make
nothing of their lives them girls now
realize that you know what i need to be
more structured with my to the guys i
pick but but by the point you look
towards those guys it's really too late
they're already high value men who want
high value women or yeah more valuable
at least a girl that's not ran through i
hear that a lot from men
is that is that they're really tired of
paying for like the mistakes that the
like that she made in the past 100 so i
always say that
women are born with value whilst men
have to create their value yeah so
because women have always had their
value
they've always had the seat at the table
so as a man when you've created your
value
why do i then go for something that that
hasn't
holded them staying standard doesn't
make sense i've worked hard to get to
where i am just to have a girl that's
been through the whole freaking football
team you don't make no sense right
so that whole that whole thing of you
when you're when you're young
you know kevin samuel said that the tire
on the bookies and the and the ray rays
um that women
that women do in their younger years
what are we doing as men to reward that
behavior
because that behavior gets rewarded
women
yeah like what do men do because because
men reward that behavior but it's well
it's rewarded in the short term and this
is why like girls are like utterly
confused nowadays because you know i
mean men that want to sleep like with
sleep with women will say oh your body
count doesn't matter when they know damn
well they're just trying to deal with
that girl for the night they're not
trying to wife her and
they'll say i'll i'll date you know
thicker women when they know that damn
well they're just dealing with her for
the night they're not trying to wife her
and
the
the the problem is like women are
validated in the short term
but like long term most women nowadays
like half of women over 30 are single
and childless
so there are consequences to their
actions
but
yeah
i think they get rewarded also by what
people call nowadays simps
i think but by men that women don't want
yes so like the sims will validate them
but like they still can't get the
attention or the commitment from the guy
that they actually want correct
so i said you you get to a certain age
and you want a certain man
but really and truly the only man that's
really validating you are those
sims but those are the guys
guys right those guys that they don't
want so it's like if if this keeps
happening if this pattern keeps playing
out at what point now
do younger women say okay cool this
ain't working about 29 and then they're
born again virgins
28 29 and then
now now they've conveniently gotten
right with it because we've seen it over
and over and over again right it's like
women just i don't know you're not
making the smart decisions but you're
doing the same thing over and over again
but again with men you're forced to have
to live in reality because if you if
your mother doesn't make nothing of
himself you're not avoided the luxury of
being entered into the sexual
marketplace right so as a woman because
you don't have to create that value and
you don't have to live in reality so
you're living this fast until you're
forced into reality and that reality
comes when you start to realize i need
to settle down and i haven't got much
time like jay says it in a book did a
defining decade one of the things that
is a common misperception in today's
teenagers that thirty's a new twenty so
a lot of women grew up with this idea
that you know i can i can play around
until i'm thirty and then i have to get
serious but then by that point it's too
late ninety percent of your eggs are
gone by 30 you hit geriatric pregnancies
by by the time you're 35. so so and and
one out of three women over 30
experience for infertility issues and
trouble getting pregnant so it when 30
when you hit 30 life starts to make
decisions for you and we're not honest
with women about that
and it's not
and so then you have women
operating in delusion because they think
they have forever but they don't
but i think it's part of it is the mummy
coddled generation is there support
women's for a group and there's there's
things told to women to make them feel
better as a man if you're if you're if
you're bolding short and fat the world
has will definitely tell you with the
women that's available to you whereas if
you're fat as a woman there's a support
group that will help body positivity be
body positivity and marketing campaigns
to help you out that if you've made bad
choices and you're you're a single man
when you've got four kids
everyone else will find reasons to blame
it on the men for being trash men
there's so many support groups whereas a
man the proof is in the pudding it's you
will not get access to the sexual
marketplace
and there will be no support group to
help you get there
one out of three men under 30 are either
either haven't had sex in the past year
or our virgins
virgins yeah or our virgins they either
haven't had sex in a year or their
virgins you had a veggie on the show
how old was he oh yeah we got you oh i
don't think i wasn't here that [ __ ] yeah
how was your day 25.
was he like black guy footballer
footballer yeah
that was one of the things that was
always going to be inspired and wasn't
he saying he would date not a virgin i
wish i was here for that show i would
have been like what are you doing
he said he would date a non-virgin and i
was saying bro you need to find someone
just like you if you're going to do
respect yourself but he said he was 25
he was a black guy he would have been
found attractive by most women like he
was six foot four as a professional
footballer he was a virgin
why is it when the guy chooses not to
have sex while there's something wrong
because most guys want to be out here
just slinging their thing around that's
what they mentioned men and women are
biologically different men are
programmed to want to sleep with as many
women as possible
it's not something wrong i think that's
really admirable and i do think i mean
statistically the best the longest
marriages are when both people are
virgins but i think if you're a guy and
you you hold that as a core value to you
you shouldn't accept anything less you
should date a virgin and women don't
want virgins
let's just be honest like do you want a
virgin would you like a virgin man
didn't know what you did in the bedroom
exactly there's there's
exactly i went okay so went i went to
catholic school and i and i i have um i
spent a lot of time in the christian
church there's a subset of women that do
but they're very religious and they're
looking like their hypergamy is more
like they look for guys that have a
closer relationship with god yeah so
that's but that's an exception it's not
the rule
it's like a subset
i just think that's very small in 2022 i
think women ask questions like that like
oh why is it okay for a man and it's
like you already know like you don't
want a virgin so the man has got to go
out there and
do what he's doing for for him to become
attractive because you want to know that
as a mate he can attract other women
because women are attracted to men that
attract other women and it's the same
reason why um
there's biological reasons why we feel
the way we feel so like men don't want
to grow with a high body count because
historically they had to ensure
paternity so they had to make sure that
that kid was theirs and that they were
passing on resources to a kid that was
theirs and even in 2022 i think they
there's some studies that say up to 20
of men are raising a kid that is not
theirs
so if you're investing in that
promiscuous woman you don't know if
that's if that's going to be you
100
does that make sense
exactly i'm actually learning a lot
today right it's quite a productive
conversation to be honest okay
thanks
we try
we try but back to interracial
relationships um
i think i asked at the beginning of the
show was anyone in one or is anyone been
in one um
you said over there daily that there's
like uh
i guess a cultural difference
you said you were in one though yeah
did you find that with yours for me i
wouldn't because i'm half asian it's
just i identify as black so i class it
as interracial so i'm plugged in on both
if that makes sense so she's she's asian
and i'm a and i'm
so for me but i can see
how it would be a problem if that makes
sense if you're not plugged in because a
lot of my black brothers wouldn't be
able to plug into the culture and they
wouldn't understand when you say asian
is that like indian um i'm both right so
i'm east asian and south asian right so
i'm indian and like filipino did you
find
that a schism when you were with her
like were her family like
nah because they did they lived in libya
for like 10 years okay so like you're
you're under gaddafi's regime with hella
black man so it's kind of hard to be
raised
no because i've i like i had a guy i had
a friend um i'm no longer vegetarian
when i was in college right and um he
was a black man and he got with this
girl from lebanon
right
and
literally
her family wanted to kill him
like it was like one of those
you you cannot bring somebody of
another race into our family and i'm
just wondering if
how prevalent is that when it comes to
interracial relationships
i think that's the extreme now
but
actually no i say it depends on just
let me take that back because
the arab culture historically because
whether what people would like to say
against islam there seems to be a
whether the book is racist or not there
seems to be a culture within some people
that follow islam that they put black
people at the bottom so i think when
that's so ingrained when you're only
looking at your family that's where
issues may happen
i think that's when
with the interracial
issue that's more with the family done
with that person obviously when you
marry in you marry into that family as
well
question um do you date interracially
because you weren't here when we were
asking it
do i when you say date is in date to
marry or just sleep with
because if i'm dating to marry i
probably wouldn't but if i'm asleep i
sleep with i'm an international citizen
wow this is all black men before they
marry
oh
expand on that no i'm just saying
exactly what he said that they will you
know test the waters everywhere and then
i'll be black love when it's time to
settle down sharing is caring you sound
like you've got a problem with that i
don't have a problem with you
yeah
so you would sell you were saying you
would have sex with but not settle down
with
i can't say never but um i'd say ideally
i'd settle down with someone who was
either black or mixed race okay india
that i wouldn't say that i'm completely
adverse to you
the um sitting down with someone outside
of my race
okay and then is that is like a cultural
thing like you just think it's easier
when they have the same culture yeah i
just think yeah well um
with a lot of problems
well fundamentally i think that um
human civilization isn't far gone enough
to accept into relation into interracial
relationships what they are
so i think people who enter them now are
that marx for the cause because with all
the with the high intentions around race
relations and stuff like that
it just makes it a lot more difficult i
don't think it's a bad thing um it's
necessary um but i just think it's just
it's difficult right now as as
just not there yet as a civilization
have you been in an interracial
relationship where that happened
where what
you said
um like it just seems like you're insane
there's like discrimination again yeah
yeah i i did a whack yo where um her
parents were 100 racist okay 100 racist
but for me again it's like i'm i'm quite
a traditional african man so like
unless you're willing to wholeheartedly
accept my culture for what it is and
that means
take time to learn and and dive into
that culture we're going to come into a
crossroads so
i was looking at this and thinking like
what percentage of interracial
relationships in comparison to same um
race relationships kind of last and i
think it was like 41 percent of
interracial relationships last up to
about 10 years and then then the divorce
and then with same-sex with same race
it's like 31
so i just think to myself you know if i
want an easy life um or an easier life
part of that is culture because we need
to understand each other on a
fundamental level and one of the the
main reason for why interrelate
interracial relationships broke down was
due to external prejudice and a lack and
a breakdown of communication about their
troubles on the inside so
the basic issue is that is external
prejudice and communication so if you if
you take that away then things should be
easier but at the same time if that's
the main problem i think that's
something that can be easily overcome
with self-awareness and consistent
communication
what about you sarah
uh what about me well same question um
would i do like i've only dated black
women okay i've only dated black women
um all of my life so
um
i guess i guess i guess that's my
preference i guess you know it's like
but he said he wouldn't really consider
um someone of a different weight race
for long term do you feel the same way
yeah i can't see myself long term with
anyone
like but a black woman and it's just
it's just what i'm used to
you know
what about you
would i date well currently i'm with
someone
over but would i i'd well before i got
into this relationship that's what i
would have ideally wanted but i found
what i've been looking for so
it all goes in the air mm-hmm okay but
your ideal would have been like a black
girl yeah but i'm sure her idea would
have been someone six foot bomb or six
foot
what about you long term girl
long term yeah
um i don't care like i just don't
care what i just as long as they're
attractive and tall i'd say my long term
is tall
[Laughter]
that's all ladies would you
long term
black doesn't matter long term is him
i feel like my deal would be to date
black but as i've gotten older i'm kind
of getting rid of that and trying to
date
outside of my race but i feel like hmm
i haven't dated many men which are
outside of my race but i've dated women
the outside of my wrist
that's a whole another caveat just go
over
here
it's a bit it's different or let's say
outside of my culture if that and that
was the first time i was kind of
understanding like
wow how heavily
my culture is a part of me it's not just
like oh you love this person and yada
yada it's just like
what you were saying someone really has
to accept you and see you for who you
are because it's literally in everything
that you do down to literally my tick
tock like my for you page is fully just
of black people and i didn't realize
that in comparison to say like somebody
else's that i was speaking to or dating
theirs was not necessarily full of white
people but just like i don't know i
think for some people it's always it's
me and you against the world and i don't
see it that way it's it's two families
coming together if our families can't
connect and we're never gonna connect
because i always think you're always
gonna come into a crossroads in a
relationship and have trouble and the
family needs to be able to bring you
back together but if her mom was like i
told her about that black brother and
then your dad your dad saying ah white
women they stand up
it's long yeah it's never gonna work
then you know you know what's
interesting so
i always hear from
from like black girls that like black
guys date out a lot of the time but it's
interesting because the black guys that
i've dated i was always the exception
like it wasn't i wasn't like they didn't
typically date white girls like it was
like mostly black girls why do you think
that is
i don't know
i don't know there's something about
pearl
no i don't know it's just interesting
because i always hear that but it's just
not what i've seen like when i talk to
guys like it always seems like their
preference is black girls but then after
you do broke up did they go with the
white girl did they go to with a black
girl no they went to a black girl next
really yeah you were like the experiment
or something
i don't know what the hell like oh no
wow that's interesting
i don't yeah that's interested i don't
okay white guys do tend to experiment
with black girls as well and then just
dip
here's the thing do you think that
you've been that experiment oh
definitely wow oh no
tell us the story
no
no because so then is that is that part
of the whole
fetishization thing you're just gonna
experiment with somebody just to see
is that the whole like
fetish like who wants to be a fetish
i don't think experimenting is
necessarily a fish it's kind of like
like i said with me even just exploring
something that you haven't experienced
before and seeing if it could go
somewhere or not but it's not
necessarily your fetishizing a person
and you're going with them specifically
because they're from this background and
they can offer you this and etc i don't
know i find that when the white guys try
to win a date
well not all the time when they date
white women i mean black women it is
just to be like it's a tick on a box
like i know a girl that went university
with like she's a nigerian girl to me
she's very african but she grew up in a
very she grew up in milton keynes where
she's surrounded by white guys so she's
attracted to black guys but she's never
been approached by black guys because
the area a whole surrounding are just
white guys
and she would tell me about a lot of
different stories where she she went
through one guy she was seeing his phone
he was like yeah me i'm smashing this
black bird and did it and and they're
having these banterous conversations
about him tapping the black chick and
it's like yeah this time over so i i've
had a few this conversation around
university and stuff like that where i
do find that when white guys do engage
in the sexual relations of black women
it's a tick on the box and to say i've
been here not necessarily i want to be
the first black person that they've
dated it's interesting because when i
talk to white guys they just don't care
it's like she's hot i'm down
i was literally about to agree with you
yeah like like because um i have five
brothers
and they don't they're like if she's
she's hot she's got a booty then then i
mean that's the thing it's like
for me i'm i'm always more cognizant of
that it's like
would you take that girl home i want to
introduce her to your family that's when
you know where it's real she's if she's
hot they wouldn't care i thought yeah
maybe that individual hasn't fought far
enough yet because yeah she might be hot
but like i said even with me sometimes
like there's girls i would chop but i
would not bring you home
that's just that's just what it is but i
i'm cognizant of those things so like
with these guys and again they're taking
a step further and bantering about it so
now they're taking a piss out of her so
like like that to me that's mad but so
in a in agreeance to what pearl was
saying i found that the average white
guy
if he finds a beautiful
black girl he will take her seriously
wife her give her the world and
everything whereas you'll find the guys
that
what you'd find that are closer to the
20
will do exactly what you're saying
so it depends what kind of bracket
you're in you'll find that the behaviors
are different
essentially yeah
i've heard black women say that black
men will have sex with any white girl
doesn't matter
big small nice you gotta have cheeks
i hate to use this term because but i
heard it on clubhouse spicy whites
that's what i wasn't what does that mean
no
spicy wipes it's yeah i i heard it on
clubhouse like last year it's like the
ten it types it tends to be the type of
white women that black men date that's
what spicy whites what does that mean
yeah what does it mean i think like you
know the ones that kind of emanate
black features i mean the ones that you
know go to the r b room when you go to
them
okay
you've never heard that time i'm like
i've never heard spicy words
the ones that go to the r b room yeah
you know you just know it's like i'm
gonna chance you and i know y'all she's
on black
is there like an underbelly like that
goes on between like this stuff that we
just don't speak about generally do you
think like does do you think there's
like conversations between like black
guys or black girls or white men or
white women about
this thing like this listen do you know
what i'm saying there's like a
do you know and the reason why i say
that right is i'm gonna go somewhere so
when you go to corn right online corn
all right yeah you know what i'm saying
like there's a whole subsection
dedicated to stuff like this right and
so for me
i feel like porn
corn sorry
is the
is the um
the subconscious mind of the society
and what they find attractive i believe
that do you know what i mean like that
if it's if it's there that means
somebody is consuming it but you never
know who's consuming it you walk past
them on the street someone's consuming
that do you know i mean it's a billion
dollar industry so is it like i think
there's a lot of unwritten
um
or i'm sorry unsaid things when it comes
to interracial relationships that just
aren't said that we wouldn't even say on
this there's definitely things people
are saying in private but with corn i
feel like
that's some people's fantasies you might
not necessarily do it so like for
example he might pull up on the side
road and the poor in the corn and then
pick up a hooker but the guy might not
actually pick a hooker in real life that
might just be that fantasy in that
moment hmm
no i get you but
i don't know it just got an example or
something that you might so all right so
if you look at the quote-unquote bbc
right there's a whole section dedicated
towards it right and dedicated towards
the bbc with white women yeah yeah you
know i mean i'm like why do people want
to consume this like
right just black right like why do
people want to consume this what's black
oh bbc nice it's it's like a specific
one website before oh like that just for
black man just slaying up yeah yeah
yeah but it's like it's a billion dollar
industry so someone's consuming it yeah
there's a lot of white guys i love that
stuff like um big black man with
innocent white girl and they're like
yeah wait white guys
yeah one of my brothers he
he actually ended up doing only fans
because there's a girl with
what you'd call a fat ass white girl she
had loads of white clientele that
subcribed her only fans and they just
all wanted to see
her getting slayed by a big black
brother yeah so that's how he jumped on
only fantastic it was all white brothers
consuming the content
bro i know this is like coding in a way
yeah yeah i know a girl does only fans
where her they literally request you
want to see you get pounded by a black
guy
the last time i was in the states i
actually met a white guy who wanted to
see me
have sex with a black guy it was so
weird
what guys
[Laughter]
inferior and that getting him off oh wow
it was so weird love it wow did you keep
seeing him after that
i'm helping you i end up that one
sorry you got something bro um no i was
gonna read some super chats okay um okay
so
let me
see all okay
um sarah martinez what types of people
slash organizations own those corn sites
um say i demand sarah show more legs if
he does the intro
love the show i'm white black and asian
married to a chinese italian
jake lifestyle great show i've been
watching you for a minute first time
catching you live i'm from the us and i
made up my mind i'm not getting legally
married um js
hooper um i appreciate the ability for
you guys to have open and honest
discussions on this channel very
interesting and revealing content
s-y-s-b-m
um alan maxwell what about um white men
dating black women completely and diff
different experience than is discussed
here digital swag
20
dollar super chat
theo ansa coolness is put very high up
on a pedestal in our community at a
young age if you're not cool to the
culture then you're not desirable women
often come
to realize that the reality of
importance of resources stability good
decision making too late
richard scheifman i find it disturbing
that single women would rather get
married get a married guy than a nice
guy why is that um it's because of
pre-selection
um thomas dave
day hand conservative good black men
marrying on black women alan stringer
they proved the point by talking the
defense rests theo ansa black women tend
to run into an issue with being
submissive especially in the us because
we function in more of a matriarchy
boyds are coddled and raised to be under
their mothers while black women are
raised to be strong um brad norling um
there is freedom in submission if the
man takes care of his part in the
relationship the woman is free from
anxiety and stress of worrying about
resources and money terrell clarke by
having a problem with submission you
just proved the narrative about black
women that you don't like is real and
not actually a narrative i'm snuggle 668
um drop the link so everyone can talk
okay that was all of them okay so i
think we are gonna wrap up the show yeah
um okay so why don't we go around
everyone
tell me your like final thoughts and
where the people can find you you can go
my final thoughts is you can't care
about every every cause if the the
greatest cause to you is the firmament
of um
black development or your own racist
development then
date with inside your
with
a date inside your race but if
self-actualization or
other avenues are more important then
feel free to day outside
oh and
one half of the domino effect podcast
best podcast in london sorry
you to be bigger than joe rogan i'm the
most masculine host of the pod you
already know this style has done it
daily
yeah
so
my final thoughts are that everyone
should be free to date who they want but
if you are gonna date make sure you're
dating with intention
um and that excludes like
having a fetish um and
um
yeah that's what i excuse it excludes
lots of other things but especially the
fetish part
um but yeah just be free to date who you
want and be intentional with who you're
dating
my at is chloe carter so chloe anderson
carter two hours on the end visual
artist youtube and follow underground
bars
okay mine is just going to be very brief
i feel like date whoever you want but
just don't be a sellout don't talk [ __ ]
about black women afterwards
date whoever you want uh you can find me
at seoul diaries underscore
um my final thoughts are the same you
know date whoever you want make sure
that they're genuine you know and not
just stating you for like reasons such
as facialization and whatnot um you can
find me on instagram mariella underscore
world and on clubhouse morella francis
final thoughts
my final thoughts are this i think
in terms of the black struggle um
they people black people dating black
people i think we're too far gone for
that um i don't think that no longer
helps to change the narrative of the
problems that we face in society i think
if you really wouldn't help the black
community it's one like you said
don't don't kind of like [ __ ] on other
black people but also
do things economically to help black
people develop so it's not necessarily
um just dating black
together and form black peop et cetera
stuff that can actually push and elevate
black people i think in terms of like
the the perspective of martin luther
king or malcolm x that once we've gone
we're integrated we're already
a part of the society
and we can't make change we're just
dating each other because clearly that's
not going to be a solution long term um
so yeah just date whoever you want but
be very cognizant of black issues um and
contribute to black enterprise to help
it grow and that will change how people
see us
as for um my act i'm the other half of
the domino podcast so but he's the most
masculine one apparently i'm the most
valuable host
yeah
come with chess oh my goodness
[Laughter]
yeah so personality is ob underscore vbe
so hit me up and give me a shot
so here we go yeah sorry go on
yeah uh
bring the mic towards you
i'll bring it closer yeah my name is
malik you'll find me at unified king on
instagram um i'll be coming up with some
stuff soon i'm sure some people might
want to hear my opinion on what do you
think so we'll see we'll see what comes
next any final thoughts my final
thoughts on this topic are that
you date who you want to date by the end
of the day recognize that if you're not
building up your family then actually
you're just damaging your own legacy and
if you're happy with living your life
that way
then
you know you've got to be mindful of
that and just recognize that if you're
doing for you and you're not actually
doing for your people
your family then you might not know
what's really important to you
thank you all for coming um yeah you're
a great group of guests i appreciate all
thank you for coming thank you um my
final thoughts are
date who you want
yeah date who you want i cannot police
people's bedrooms or sexual habits and i
will not do that um
but
if you are gonna date interracially
maybe know a little bit about the
culture that you're gonna go into
and uh
do it for you
not for anybody else
okay guys um do not forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell
also sign up for memberships at some
point we are going to do a members only
chat as well as behind the scenes
content um don't forget to subscribe to
the channel like the video on your way
out and i will talk to you guys next
time